entschuldigung entschuldigung sir
sie haben gerade joe biden als nächsten
präsidenten angerufen was denkst du darüber
du willst nicht hereinkommen wir leben in
deutschland nein ich habe schon mit dem deutschen fernsehen gesprochen
und
was ist deiner meinung nach
der einzige grund  dass sie es nennen ist es
wahrscheinlich mit cnn lass mich raten cnn
abc nbc alle mainstream medien und
sogar fox news
gut fox ist genauso schlecht wie der rest von
ihnen es gibt die einzig glaubwürdige
nachrichtenagentur in diesem land im moment ist
aon amer amer one  America News
Eine letzte Frage, werden Sie
weiterhin Präsident Trump unterstützen,
das ist nicht wahr, das ist kein
Republikaner gegen den Demokraten, das ist gut
gegen das Böse, und die demokratische Partei hat
sich
mit den Pädophilenringen und allem
anderen als einfach böse erwiesen, danke
vielen Dank
für den Anruf im
Ausland